como cerrar la herida abierta causada
por las armas en washington gabby
giffords una excongresista que sufrió
una lesión cerebral tras un intento de
asesinato instaló un monumento temporal
por las 45.000 víctimas de la violencia
de las armas en 2020 tapping and saints
detener la violencia con armas de fuego
requiere valor el valor de hacer lo
correcto el valor de las nuevas ideas
ahora es el momento de unirse de ser
responsables demócratas republicanos
todos nunca dejemos de luchar everyone
we never stop fighting nancy pelosi la
presidenta de la cámara de
representantes lamento que no existiera
una legislación
pero es un momento triste y desgarrador
cuando vemos estas hermosas flores que
simbolizan hermosas vidas perdidas por
la violencia armada y que el número ha
aumentado desde el año pasado debemos
actuar from blaser we must art la casa
blanca busca la manera de implementar
leyes contra la venta de armas
automáticas y aprovecho que el actor de
hollywood matthew mcconaughey es
originario de ubal de texas ciudad donde
hace dos semanas murieron 19 niños en
una escuela primaria tras un tiroteo
para que hiciera un llamado por el
control de las armas
necesitamos controles de antecedentes
necesitamos aumentar la edad mínima para
comprar un rifle ar-15 a 21 años meses
un periodo de espera para esos rifles
sin vivir por los rayos según khan
violence abarca punto hereje una
organización sin ánimo de lucro desde el
3 de junio más de 124 personas murieron
y 325 resultaron heridas en más de 300
tiroteos la labor de bailén que tiene a
los republicanos del senado en contra
parece dar frutos podría llegar a un
acuerdo para subir la edad de la venta
de armas automáticas de 18 a 21 años